ne m'est que de l'huile sur le
feu. Après, on ne voit pas
Jacaudrey Charbonneau.
- Le pays manque d'eau,
(tirs)
Alors que les gangs criminels
ont pris le contrôle des sources
de ravitaillement et d'une
Haïti est secoué par une énième
crise de violence,ssé
le gouvernement d'Ariel Henry
à demander l'intervention armée
dont les États-Unis
et le Canada.nada.nada.
WEIBERT ARTHUS,
ambassadeur d'Haïti au Canada
de la situation actuelle sans
ctive de la communauté
internationale.
- C'est de la violence, ce quene
nous fait.
- Pourtant, c'est loin d'être
l'avis de Jean Ernest Pierredeïe
à Montréal, qui se rallie plutôt
à celle des Haïtiens sortis dans
les rues depuis cette demande
d'ingérence étrangEST PIERRE, at
et PDG de la radio CPAM1410
- Le peuple dit : "Non, on ne
veut pas de cette intervention-
là." Ec'est pareil, pire que c'.
- La situation a d'ailleurs d'us
l'assassinat de Joinat de Joinï.
Ariel Henry est à la têtesans l,
cet expert.
ROROMME CHANTAL, prof. science
- À aucun moment depuis
vée, il n'a fait aucun
effort pour résoudre le problème
des gangs. Ce n'esoù la populate
contre son gouvernement et e
son départ qu'il s'empresse
de demander à la communauté
dans l'immédiat une force
internationale armée.
- Une façon donc de s'accrocher
au pouvoir, alors que le pays
connaît aussi une résurgencera.
- La situation est très, t
alarmante. Les médias confirment
la mort déjà au cours de plusies
dizaines de personnes.
FREDERIC BOISROND, sociologue
- Actuellement, il y a
sont en insécurité alimentaire.a
des vols, il y a des viols,
et les écoles sont fermées...
Il y a un arrêt de la vie
quotidienne des gens.
Je pense que c'est pas à nous
de propolutions.
- Devant l'urgence,
les É
à renforcer l'aide humanitaire
sans toufirmer l'envoi
de troupes en sol haïtien
pour le moment. Leité de l'ONU t
se réunir la semaine prochaine.
Ici Jacaudrey Charbonneau,
Radio-Canada, Mon